le 299 monsieur cabanel oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
cet amendement et la mana mana mon
collègue christian bilhac cet article
vise à interdire l'exploitation des
services aériens sur les liaisons
intérieures au territoire national dès
lors qu'un trajet alternatif par notre
moyen de transport collectif au moins
émetteurs de co2 existe un moins de 2h30
cette mesure aurait un impact important
sur l'attractivité de certains
territoires et sur les citoyens qui
pourraient voir leur temps de trajet
longe et sans oublier les difficultés de
la mise en oeuvre quant à
l'identification des vols concernés les
liaisons aériennes et un vital pour un
territoire enclavé les industrie et pme
dont la compétitivité est dépeint comme
cela était excellemment rappelé par la
mission d'information sénatoriale sur
les transports aériens et l'aménagement
du territoire rapportés par notre ancien
collègue josiane cost le présent
amendement vise donc à supprimer cet
article
merci à vis de la commission sera
porteur le président je vais donner un
je vais demander le retrait de cet
amendement ou un avis défavorable
en effet sept
article au final ne comprend qu'une
ligne de manière effective entre
bordeaux et paris
pour autant une liaison va continuer à
exister entre bordeaux et roissy
notamment pour les vols au niveau des
correspondances si on a un amendement
l'espèce pour pouvoir permettre de
maintenir cette ligne avec plus de 50%
des passagers en correspondance qui veut
dire que des vols domestiques pourront
continuer à avoir lieu entre bordeaux et
et roissy et vous dire également que la
commission n'a pas souhaité aller plus
loin par rapport aux différentes
demandes qui ont été faits par un
certain nombre de collègues sans même
parler des demandes de la convention
citoyenne et vous dire également vous
l'avez entendu tout à l'heure à travers
l'article précédent
nous avons souhaité sanctuary lisez un
certain nombre de lignes d'aménagement
du territoire auquel je sais les uns et
les autres vous êtes particulièrement
attachés et de plus on ne peut que
reconnaître même s'il n'est pas encore
totale qu'un report modal assez
conséquent existe au niveau aujourd'hui
du trains entre bordeaux et paris
encore faut-il et nous serons très
vigilants sur ces questions que le
service la sncf soit la hauteur de
de l'enjeu puisque je sais que il y a un
besoin croissant de déplacement entre
cette grande ville de province qui
bordeaux est notre capitale voilà la
raison pour laquelle je vous demande de
retirer votre amendement sinon un avis
défavorable à vis du gouvernement madame
la ministre
merci monsieur le président sans
surprise le gouvernement n'est pas
favorable à cet amendement de
suppression de l'article
nous sommes partis comme vous le savez
de l'avis de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat qui proposait
l'interdiction des lignes aériennes
lance qu'une alternative de moins de
quatre heures existe ce texte a été
retravaillé pour arriver à l'idée d'une
alternative de moins de 2h30 en prenant
en compte la question des
correspondances et il me semble que du
coup les lignes touchées qui sont
concernées sont par ailleurs toutes
desservies par le tgv ce qui permettra
comme l'a dit monsieur le rapporteur une
bonne une bonne desserte multimodal vous
signaler dans votre amendement les
objections juridiques elles sont connues
nous y travaillons avec la commission
européenne et nous considérons comme
l'indiqué le conseil constitutionnel que
l'objectif de libre circulation peut
être conciliée avec l'autre objectif de
valeur constitutionnelle qu'est la
protection de l'environnement c'est donc
une demande de retrait ou bien sûr un
avis défavorable
il est maintenu il est maintenu je mets
donc aux voix l'amendement 299 avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour
bah oui quand même qui est contre
il est rejeté quatre amendements
discussion commune d'abord le 1093
monsieur dantec
oui j'espère que cet amendement ne
vaudra pas un procès pour mollesse
puisque nous ne reprenons pas exactement
la proposition de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat il faut dire
que nous ne nions pas engagé
formellement à la différence du
président de la république c'est à dire
que au lieu de proposer quatre heures
nous proposons trois heures et demie
trois heures et demie c'est le paris
marseille et c'est aussi ce qui
correspond à ses un maximum de retour d'
aller retour dans la journée je je
voulais dire que on a été un peu surpris
que le rapporteur ne supprime pas
totalement l'article et je trouve que
c'est assez intéressante finalement on
est gardé cet article même pour deux
heures et demie ce qui correspond c'est
très symbolique il ya une ligne
concernée mais en gardons l'article et
là aussi je voulais donc rendre hommage
la majorité sénatoriale en gare dans
l'arctique vous dites bien vous dit bien
qu'il y a un vrai coût environnemental
spécifique du transport aérien et que ça
n'est pas neutre de faire deux heures et
demie en avion et ça c'est important
qu'il y ait consensus là dessus pour
dire ça n'est pas un transport comme les
autres son coût environnemental et
supérieur et merci au reporter et à
l'ensemble de la majorité sénatoriale
pour avoir souligné ce point important à
partir de là par contre faire un
amendement au complet pour une ligne
c'est quand même pas beaucoup donc nous
on revient à 3h30 je présume que ça va
provoquer quelques débats dans
l'assemblée alors c'est comme tout à
l'heure pour la convention de chicago ne
partons pas dans de faux débats tels que
ses écrits par le rapporteur et nous
avons gardé strictement la manière dont
s'est écrite
évidemment au
d'aménagement du territoire n'est
concerné nous ne parlons pas d'aurillac
ne parlons pas d'argent nous parlons de
plates formes aéroportuaires qui sont
sur les lignes tgv donc si vous avez
dans vos argumentaires prévu de parler
d'aménagement du territoire nous aussi
nous l'avons totalement intégré c'est
marqué dans notre objet par contre
derrière
effectivement il y as d'autres questions
intéressantes qui ne sont pas venus dans
le débat et en 15 secondes ne viendront
pas beaucoup monsieur le président qui
est que dans les enjeux sur lequel on
n'est pas revenu
il ya quand même la desserte en tgv
d'orly parce qu'il y a des gens qui ont
besoin d'aller prendre l'avion à orly
que la virgule de l'essonne
la connexion entre tgv à et orly reste
faible et que ça ça devrait atteindre un
vestige ma priorité aujourd'hui aller le
1596 monsieur de vinasse merci monsieur
le président écoute et nous si nous
considérons que deux heures trente et un
côté symbolique et que ça n'est pas
suffisant et les auteurs de cet
amendement propose d'élargir aux trajets
aériens dont une alternative par le
train de moins de trois heures existent
pour autant nous sommes aussi vigilants
sur les impacts de la mesure que nous
proposons et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous souhaitons conditionné
l'application de cette interdiction à la
réalisation au préalable d'une étude
d'impact et nous souhaitons que cette
étude d'impact puissent être réalisés
par des organismes publics indépendants
et pluralistes habilité à réaliser ce
type d'étude
merci le 98 de oui je vous en prie merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues je te demande de manque
porte notre collègue de milly la
restriction du trafic aérien en plus
d'avoir de fortes conséquences
économiques
pourquoi un secteur déjà fortement
touchée par l'actrice viendra limiter la
liberté de l'industrie et la liberté de
déplacement pour les particuliers les
lignes nationales
menacé de disparition sont très
importantes pour les voyageurs en
correspondance ou en déplacement
professionnel et pour le maintien de la
connectivité entre les différentes
villes
de plus la suppression de ces
différentes lignes aurait de graves
conséquences locales en termes de pertes
d'emplois les aéroports constitue un
atout essentiel pour l'attractivité
économique logistique et d'aménagement
d'un territoire la réponse est d'offrir
une alternative ferroviaire avec des
prix attractifs
une régularité assurée et un service
intérieur professionnels le présent
amendement vise donc à interdire
l'exploitation de services aériens sur
des liaisons intérieures nationale dès
lors qu'un trajet alternatif moins
émetteurs de co2 existe alors moi je
propose dans cet amendement en moins de
deux heures merci et un amendement
identique le 239 monsieur cazabonne oui
juste rajouter quelques éléments on
mélange parfois le le rejet co2 de
compagnies aériennes je rappelle que
l'article 2 qui est paru sur les écoles
de l'espace européen disent que 24 % des
vols qui pourrait être remplacé par le
trajet à un lgv ne représentent que 3 8%
du rejet co2 ce sont les vols
internationaux qui a ici pour cent du
trafic représente 47 gil 6 % du co2
rejeté donc par rapport aux lignes
bordeaux jusqu'en haut niveau qu'à
l'instant bordeaux orly j'avoue que j'ai
pas trouvé de lignes de chemin de fer
faisant orly mérignac
holy bordeaux oui kim et de 0,4 pour
aller d'orly secteur aéroportuaire à
celui de mérignac secteur aéroportuaire
il faut 3h30 dans toute une partie dans
paris et dans bordeaux avait des
véhicules thermiques
c'est pour ça que dans un autre
amendement plus tard je demanderai ski
un report de sa qui rejoignait
l'amendement précédent pour dire
étudions sérieusement ça avait des
organismes indépendants pour une
position nette pour l'instant je suis
d'accord avec les deux heures proposée
par denise saint pé
bien à vis de la commission donc sur les
amendes sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements
merci monsieur le président c'est pas
simple chacun donne son horaire ce sera
dur et faire une synthèse pour vous dire
je reste sur la position qui a été
décidé en commission dès 2h30
monsieur dantec pour vous répondre tout
le monde prend sa part de sur la
décarbonation est strictement sa part
gelé dit lors de mon propos liminaire le
la et ria le fait l'aérien des projets
pour décarbonés pour des biocarburants
ça a été suffisamment dit je crois qu'il
faut le répéter donc un effort est
demandé c'est normal nous avons voté au
début de ce texte des ambitions
importantes pour notre pays pour
respecter au niveau international un
certain nombre d'engagements et l'aérien
on prend toute sa part mais c'est
également le cas des autres transports
le transport routier de voyageurs
également le fait est
et va accentuer ses efforts de letra je
vous rappelle quand même qu'il ya un
certain nombre de lignes qui ne sont pas
électrifiés dans notre pays des trains
qui circulent au diesel ça puait
existait aussi dans notre pays
donc voilà aussi à au grand opérateur
ferroviaire de faire des efforts comme
le font ou vont le faire les les
les opérateurs sur sur la r ya donc
simplement moi ce que je voudrais vous
dire c'est que je vais donner des avis
de retrait vous proposait de retirer ou
des avis défavorables sur sur vos
amendements et je souhaite qu'on garde
de cette ligne des deux heures enfin
ceux de deux heures trente qui sont ce
qu a fixé le gouvernement
j'aimerais dire aussi et pour avoir
auditionné tous les acteurs que tout le
monde à intégrer ça que les compagnies
déjà ont intégré le fait qu'elle
n'exploiterait plus ces lignes dans le
cadre d'un accord très probablement avec
le gouvernement par contre je vous
rappelle que nous resterons très
attentifs à ce que les choses n'évoluent
pas et que les 2h30 ne se transforme pas
plus tard en 3h30 ou 4h30 et bien sûr
que le report modal puisse se faire dans
les meilleures conditions possibles et
je pense notamment à nos amis bordelais
qui sont principalement pénalisé par
cette mesure
merci à vis du gouvernement va dans la
ministre merci monsieur le président je
vais être défavorable à ces amendements
est allé dans le sens exprimé par
monsieur le rapporteur les 2h30 c'est
évidemment un compromis l'objectif de
ces deux heures trente c'est de dire que
on est en capacité de faire l'aller
retour dans la journée pour quelqu'un
qui a un déplacement professionnel qui
vient pour une réunion de travail et qui
doit pouvoir repartir
2h30 c'est aussi l'équivalent du temps
qu'on m'ait centre-ville à centre-ville
pour un vol en avion
lorsque il s'agit d'aller à l'aéroport
de prendre l'avion et puis de quitter
l'aéroport et donc avis défavorable aux
amendements qui allonge beaucoup cette
durée parce que ça ne permet plus de
faire l'aller retour
dans la journée et avis défavorable aux
amendements qui la réduisent parce que
là ça veut dire si on passait à deux
heures qu'on n'aurait plus aucun vol qui
seraient concernés et donc on viderait
totalement la mesure des faits et donc
je propose d'en rester au compromis qui
a été établie y compris comme sur le
rapporteur l'a dit avec les différents
acteurs concernés qui s'y préparent
merci je vais donc mettre voix
l'ensemble de ces amendements qui ont
deux avis négatifs le 1093 qui est pour
et qui est contre
il est rejeté le 1596 qui est pour et
qui est contre
il est rejeté même vote pour le 98
comment cela moeurs
non mais c'est peut-être l'un vers ce
pays ces mêmes votes peut-être quand
même alors sur le 98 avec deux avis
négatifs qui est pour bat vais pas
changer grand chose qui est contre il
est rejeté plus nettement
et le 239 qui est identique pareil elle
est trois amendements discussion commune
le 1772 n'est pas défendu le 2116
monsieur marchand
merci monsieur le président il s'agit
d'un amendements rédactionnels
l'arctique que nous examinons interdit
l'exploitation de services aériens
lorsqu'il existe une alternative
ferroviaire satisfaisante à la niel ni
né à saint qu'ils aient figuré le mot
aéronefs
or il semble plus cohérent de prendre en
compte le service aérien dans son
ensemble pour évaluer la performance
environnementale du transport aérien que
le seul aéronefs merci et le 240
monsieur cazabonne oui c'est ce que je
vais annoncer ce qu'il appelle mon amant
de repli je rappelle que cet homme cette
décision assez arbitraire de suppression
de la ligne a quand même posé beaucoup
de questions sur le plan girondins non
seulement entreprises surtout
entreprises mais également aux élus en
effet aujourd'hui je peux je dépose un
amendement qui devrait permettre au
gouvernement si je finis de reprendre la
main notamment pour ce qui concerne la
concertation
parce que la décision a été prise sans
aucune concertation j'ai eu l'occasion
de manet monsieur gilles baril un rendez
vous au nom non seulement - nathalie
delattre deux parlementaires de la
majorité de sénateurs présidents du
département président la métropole
j'ai eu comme réponse une lettre poli
mais qui était de 9,6 à 30 traduit en
français courant
circulez ya rien à voir c'est décidé
donc je souhaiterais que l'on n'en
reprenne la main là dessus avec un délai
d'application
pourquoi on dirait application parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun lien
direct entre les aéroports et les gares
dans un moyen direct au dans 18 mois
environ il y aura un métro à paris un
tramway à bordeaux
ce qui fait qu'à son allant pour
effectivement voir une amélioration sur
le plan de l'écologie mais également une
amélioration sur les temps de
déplacement du secteur aéroportuaire
d'orly jusqu'à celui de 2000 rien c'est
pour ça que j'ai demandé un report de
cette décision après une étude sérieuse
comme on l'a dit menées par différents
société ou études j'ai pas indépendante
merci avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur le président concernant
l'amendement de monsieur marchand je lui
propose je demande au gouvernement son
avis en la matière et puis concernant
monsieur casabonne j'ai bien envie de et
je vais le faire d'ailleurs de proposer
un avis de sagesse sous réserve des
décisions peut-être de l'aber france qui
a peut-être anticipé les choses mais en
tout cas retarder de quelques mois pour
que les personnes puissent s'organiser
quand à l'entrée en vigueur de la cet
ce changement dans la vie quotidienne ou
en tout cas hebdomadaires d'un certain
nombre de bordelais ou de parisiens est
quelque chose qu ici là notre assemblée
le souhaite peut être prise en compte en
tout cas je propose un avis de sagesse à
vis du gouvernement madame lise sur les
deux amendements
merci monsieur le président sur
l'amendement 21-16 c'est un avis
favorable à un amendement rédactionnelle
tout à fait utile sur l'amendement 240
et sur le report de la date d'entrée en
vigueur
bien sûr on a besoin de concerter et ces
sujets doivent nécessite des discussions
approfondies locale mais à un moment
c'est aussi une décision extrêmement
politique qui est prise par le
gouvernement et qui sera votée ou pas
vers ces assemblées pour savoir quel est
le bon compromis
et le compromis dont on discute celui
sur lequel nous avons atterri c'est un
compromis à 2h30 qui concerne de notre
point de vue trois liaisons ses liaisons
ne sont actuellement pas opérés par air
france et le travail a déjà commencé
pour voir comment aller vers
l'intermodalité la substitution comment
répondre aux questions très concrètes
que vous posez de gex de jonction entre
les différentes zones aéroportuaires et
il y a des solutions
il y aurait un contre signal donné à
renvoyer l'application a plus loin
éventuellement à permettre une
réouverture d'exploitation temporaire de
céline qui ont vocation à fermer
néanmoins donc pour des raisons de
lisibilité de cohérence est d'ailleurs
aussi d'urgence climatique
la position du gouvernement est vraiment
défavorables au report à l'entrée en
vigueur
très bien je vais commencer par le 21 16
qui a donc au final deux avis favorable
puisque la commission s'aligner sur le
gouvernement
donc le 21 16 avec deux avis favorables
et pour qui est contre il est adopté et
le 240 tonnes à vide sagesse de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour
là c'est pas clair c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
je sais bien que je gomme voilà alors
sur le 240 à vis de sagesse de la
commission défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour lever la main pour de bon
son qui sont pour de bon
qui est contre
il est rejeté deux amendements font
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 54
qui le défend il est pas des formes
le 55 non plus de 1682 monsieur de
vinasse oui merci monsieur le président
c'est amendements visent dans une
certaine mesure à rétablir de l'équité
sociale dans les mesures que prévoit cet
article 36 les vols en jet privé aux
tarifs inabordables pour une grande
majorité de la population ont des effets
délétères sur l'environnement ils
émettent dix fois plus de co2 par
personne que les liaisons aériennes
commerciales déjà très polluante par
rapport à d'autres modes de transport en
moyenne un vol privé de quatre heures
génère autant d'émissions qu'un individu
moyen en une année d'ailleurs entre 2005
et 2010 9 les émissions de co2 des jets
privés en europe ont augmenté de près
d'un tiers soit plus rapidement que les
émissions de l'aviation commerciale et
de manière exponentielle depuis la crise
de l'aco vide 19
la france est l'un des pays européens
qui effectue le plus de trajets en jet
privé or il serait particulièrement
discriminatoire de supprimer d'un côté
les service régulier de transport aérien
public de passagers en raison des
émissions de gaz à effets de fait de
serre qu'elle génère sans interdire de
l'autre celle des jets privés plus
polluants l'application de cette
interdiction aurait aussi l'immense
avantage d'encourager les constructeurs
les compagnies et les usagers à investir
fortement dans la recherche et le
développement en faveur de solutions
durables et vertes pour le mode de
transport aérien merci avis du
rapporteur demande d'avis du
gouvernement s'il vous plaît avait des
gouvernements merci monsieur le
rapporteur
c'est un avis défavorable pour les
raisons que je vais je vais vous
expliquer en fait la notion de jets
privés
n'a pas d'existence juridique soit le
vol est réalisée par une compagnie
aérienne
et dans ce cas il rentre dans le cadre
européen du transport public
il n'y a pas de discrimination au seul
motif du type d'avions utilisés soit le
vol est organisée sans passer par une
compagnie aérienne
ce qui veut dire que c'est un citoyen
qui d'une part dispose hulu un aéronef
et de l'autre il engage un pilote privé
dans ce cas ces vols ne sont pas
couverts par le règlement européen
concerné et du coup une extension de
l'interdiction à ces vols remettrait
fondamentalement en cause la liberté
d'aller et venir
john certaine manière ça reviendrait à
interdire l'usagé de la voiture
lorsqu'il existe une alternative en
transport en commun et donc je comprends
le sens de cet amendement mais
juridiquement c'est un avis défavorable
enfin bien bon se calmer ya pas de quoi
se met dans des états pareils
rassurez vous les français sont fascinés
par nos explications de votre lieu de
vie naze monsieur devine à qui monsieur
le président madame la ministre le
président de la république a demandé à
vingt-six économistes en rapports qui
lui ont remis hier quand vous l'aurez lu
vous verrez que vous pourrez qu'être
d'accord avec la demande mans que je
propose vous êtes en train de créer une
exception est l'exception qui est en
train de créer
mais tout par terre j'ai le questeur
cave au canada
après simplement rappelé à la haute
assemblée que la france compte avec
dassault aviation al des leaders
mondiaux du secteur
peut-être le meilleur à nos à nos yeux
en tout cas et que nous gagnons des
parts de marché à l'étranger que nous
sommes une référence reconnue qui a un
savoir faire qu'il y a des usines en
france dans ce domaine de l'aviation dit
d'affaires mais qui en fait la façon
d'avoir des vols qui ne sont pas
réguliers qui sont du point à point et
qui s'adapte à une demande
quand une entreprise travaille en europe
quand elle a une à une usine en pologne
wire qu'elle doit y envoyer des équipes
techniques et bien préfère prendre un
avion d'affaires qui lui permet
simplement d'aller au plus près du site
qu'elle doit desservir plutôt que passer
par des grands aéroports de perdre des
heures entières et ça offre une
souplesse pour partir à l'heure
souhaitée
alors c'est un secteur qui connaît une
crise importante cercle des articles
indiquant qu'avec le coville ils ont eu
un petit regain mais je veux dire
simplement qu'il reste une compagnie je
crois française sur le sujet est en tout
cas un très grand constructeur que nous
aimons et ce serait vraiment un très
mauvais signal que la haute assemblée
disent qu'elles refusent les secteurs
d'excellence
monsieur dantec alors il se trouve que
j'avais proposé un amendement qui
parlait comme de cette aviation
d'affaires qui ne peut pas passer à
travers notre discussion qui a été
victime chez plus un quinqua 41 ou 1,45
en tout cas le malheureux n'a pas
survécu c'est un 41 ans après oui je
crois qu'il y faisait tous les trois la
totale mais malgré tout malgré tout il
posait la question qui reste totalement
légitime
lui en parler avec avec notre rapporteur
qui est de dire qu'on est quand même
dans une situation incroyable qui est
que ce sont des vols coûteux et ce sont
des vols qui échappe à toute taxation
vincent capo-canellas dit un peu
malicieusement tout à l'heure en
rappelant qu effectivement nous avons
augmenté la taxe de solidarité dite taxe
chirac en la rapprochant du coût du co2
qui n'est pas faux mais ça ne s'applique
pas à l'aviation d'affaires
il n'y a aucun élément qui s'applique à
l'aviation d'affaires
alors madame la ministre quelles
seraient vos propositions
ce que vous êtes mieux armés que nous
pour faire l'article de loi qui va bien
pour que l'aviation d'affaires paye
quand même une partie du coût notamment
de ses émissions parce que ce qui arrive
quand même et il ya eu quand même
beaucoup d'articles sur l'aviation
d'affaires il faut faire attention aussi
que demain soit par rapport aux
inquiétudes de vincent capo-canellas sur
son avenir économique qu'elle soit
tellement stigmatiser qu'elle est aussi
d'autres difficultés d'image et
notamment parce qu'elle ne paye pas ses
propres coûts donc est ce que là on
remet une taxation du kérosène
est-ce qu'on en étant on trouve le moyen
d'étendre la taxe de solidarité c'était
notre proposition j'aimerais bien vous
entendre parce que sinon on est dans la
justice sociale et on sera de plus en
plus dans la non-acceptation social
houlgate
c'est le président mesdames et messieurs
chers collègues c'est pour répondre à
monsieur capo-canellas il en aucun cas
question d'interdire l'aviation
d'affaires il s'agit d'avoir un
parallélisme des formes ans qui est prêt
ce qui est prévu pour les compagnies
aériennes et l'aviation d'affaires à
partir du moment où il ya une
alternative possible en train sans
discontinuité sur une durée qui est
d'une durée de 2h30
merci je mets aux voileux 1682 avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour
qui est contre
il est rejetée le 8 178 le 629 je n'ai
pas vu deux défenseurs ce qu'on sort le
8 178
oui je vous en prie monsieur cozic merci
monsieur le président le développement
durable nous conduit à combiner
plusieurs objectifs parfois
difficilement conciliables disons qu'il
faut satisfaire à des exigences globales
planétaire des exigences locales de vie
quotidiennes avec parfois des
contradictions dont il faut sortir par
le haut le présent amendement prend
racine des recommandations de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé en
matière de seuils sonore à ne pas
dépasser
l' oms indique dans un rapport de 2018
qu'un niveau supérieur de bruit est
associé à des effets néfastes sur la
santé
un rapport de bruitparif pointer les
impacts sanitaires du bruit des
transports qui au delà de la seule
nuisance doivent être appréhendés comme
la seconde cause de morbidité derrière
la pollution atmosphérique qui
correspond à dix mois à trois ans de vie
en bonne santé en moins pour le trafic
ferroviaire selon l' oms ces valeurs
sont fixé à 54 décibels le jour et 44
décibels la nuit
nous sommes en france à 60 pour le jour
et 55 pour la nuit
vous savez le brouilly est un marqueur
la qualité de vie ce à la fois un
phénomène complexe avec ses folles et
avec ses volets physique physiologique
et psychologique
c'est aussi un phénomène fugitif mais
ancré dans l'organisation des
territoires des infrastructures le bruit
ferroviaire l'illustrent parfaitement
les contradictions qu'il faut affronter
deux légitimités s'opposent souvent d'un
côté la performance environnementale du
rail plus économes en énergie et en
carbone et en espace et de l'autre
l'environnement sonore des populations
riveraines deux exigences à concilier
dans les projets nouveaux comme dans la
gestion courante des lignes existantes
toute approche qui négligerait une de
ces exigences conduire est un échec
l'article 36 en fermant certaines lignes
aériennes ne va pas supprimer le flux de
passagers entre ces destinations
il est fortement probable que ces
passagers se rabat sur le train de fait
cela va demander une intensification des
rotations pour la sncf
intensifiant donc de manière connexe le
passage des trains sur les lignes le
présent amendement vise donc à demander
un rapport remis tous les six mois au
parlement afin d'appréhender les
conséquences concrètes en matière de
nuisances sonores du depor de passagers
aériens empruntés en plus les lignes
fermées sur les lignes ferroviaires avis
de la commission sur la porter chers
collègues j'entends votre votre question
et le problème des nuisances sonores en
général est un est un problème un vrai
problème
après vous avez été dans votre groupe
un certain nombre à parler de cet après
midi beaucoup du train de développer les
trains d'équilibré du territoire les
trains de jour les trains de nuit les
transversales les tgv les ter
après vous demander un rapport sur les
nuisances sonores ferroviaire par
rapport à la fermeture des lignes
aériennes
vous avez entendu notre discours il ya
simplement une ligne aérienne qui est
concerné donc on peut demander un
rapport au gouvernement si si vous le
souhaitez mais sincèrement c'est pas
cohérent par rapport à la décision de le
lier avec la fermeture de lignes
aériennes on sait que que ce sera
quelque chose de très faibles donc pour
cette raison demandent de le retirer
je vous propose sinon un avis
défavorable tout en demandant vraiment
au gouvernement d'être particulièrement
vigilants aux nuisances sonores
ferroviaire qui seraient induites par la
montée en puissance peut-être du tgv
entre bordeaux et paris
madame la ministre merci au fait votre
amendement pose une vraie question sur
la lutte contre les suit les nuisances
sonores dans le cas du ferroviaire et
c'est un sujet sur lequel le ministre
est régulièrement interpellé auquel il
apporte une attention particulière il y
a dans les mesures du plan de relance un
certain nombre de mesures
avec une enveloppe de 120 millions
d'euros pour la résorption des nuisances
sonores le long du réseau ferré national
donc l'attention portée aux nuisances
ferrovial usant sonore du ferroviaire
est forte et je voudrais la réaffirmer
ici
après c'est pas la fermeture des lignes
aériennes concernées par l'attitude 36
qui organisera un report majeur puisque
sur la ligne la plus chargée qui est le
pari bordeaux on a un million de
voyageurs annuels par part l'avion et 20
millions par le train donc le report
voyez n'a pas d'impact majeur sur
l'intensification du trafic dès lors
c'est un avis défavorable à cet
amendement est à cette demande de
rapport qui en plus est ce une demande
de rapport tous les six mois
mais une attention réaffirmé du
gouvernement sur la lutte contre les
nuisances sonores dans le ferroviaire
merci monsieur de nicolet oui mais la
mamie ce monsieur c'est la porter le
président moi je soutiens mon collègue
sarthois sur 7
cet amendement je sais que les rapports
n'ont pas apporté grand chose dans la
dans les sillons et madame la ministre
24 parlementaires depuis un an
demande un entretien au midi des
transports pour étudier de façon très
précise ce problème du bruit sous les
lits sncf notamment sud ouest et puis
une bretagne le loire atlantique
on n'a toujours pas on n'a toujours pas
eu de réponse
23 parlementaire devant le gouvernement
un peu d'attention parce que tous les
riverains en ont assez vous nous
expliquer que yvert 120 millions ou 130
millions de plus dans le plan de relance
personnes étaient au courant et donc
tous les élus qui sont en charge de ces
problèmes de lignes ne sont pas au
courant et quand on pose la question
comme je lé fais la dernière fois
monsieur djebbari en commission il a
répandu qui avait 11 millions pour la
ligne sud ouest et 5 millions pour la
libreta n'y a tenté qu'il n'a absolument
pas parlé du plan de relance
est ce que vous êtes un peu notre
interprète notre interprète une fois de
plus auprès du ministre mais je
je ne sais pas si je vais prendre le
train tout à l'heure alors moi je
l'entendrai à l'intérieur mais est un
interprète pour que véritablement il y
ait un dialogue entre 23 parlementaires
et le gouvernement sur ce problème qui
concerne des milliers de des milliers de
personnes qui sont au bord de ces lignes
merci oui monsieur cozic simplement oui
pour compléter compléter les propos je
partage complètement les propos de mon
collègue de nicolet l'a simplement le
madame la ministre ce que j'entends vos
propos ce que je vous demande c'est
d'évaluer les politiques publiques ont
mis en oeuvre il ya une décision qui est
prise de supprimer des lignes aériennes
souvent il ya des décisions qui sont
prises et on regarde paul les effets ben
moi ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on
puisse évaluer les politiques publiques
et sur un sujet comme celui là ça me
paraît déraisonnable que d'avancer à la
boxe très bien je mets aux voileux 878
qui a donc deux avis négatifs qui est
pour
qui est contre il est rejeté je mets au
voile article 36 quai pour qui est
contre il est adopté
[Musique]